[Musique]
vous l'avez trouvé où est-il qu'il
faudrait cesser la commande alors ça
m'arrange pas des masses parce que j'ai
un contrôle tu parles comme si tu avais
un vrai boulot eh ben j'ai un vrai
boulot ce graphiste
si j'étais toi je me méfierais de cette
manne
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce terrain marguerite
quelle est cette tenue marguerite et
tout va bien madame haidar hidjab est
encore à l'écart nous sommes le 12
février 2005 rabon occupe malien poule
c'était la salle rome ah ouais ton envie
de m'emmerder des passes ta peur du
ridicule fini à cayres je viens du futur
qui doit avoir des informations sur la
guerre le débarquement en normandie
la grande vadrouille même toit rappelait
rattraper ses commandements du mois là
je peux pas travailler parce que
et au jeu tout en retenue
djamel retrouver un huissier de la magie
existe c'est quoi le temps d'un week-end
trop cher google fait c'est l'étape et à
la réponse est ce que tu veux je vais
faire un truc rohff
[Musique]